[Música]
en France 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos en esta ocasión iniciamos
en Moscú la capital rusa una ciudad que
cuenta con una de las redes de
videovigilancia más avanzadas del mundo
en 2017 la alcaldía anunció Que en total
había 160.000 cámaras instaladas y más
de 3000 de ellas estaban conectadas a un
sistema de reconocimiento facial durante
la pandemia fueron claves para imponer
multas pero también desde 2021 según una
investigación de la agencia reuters
jugaron un papel clave para identificar
y posteriormente arrestar a
manifestantes después de que Rusia
invadió Ucrania en 2022 Incluso se usó
esta red para evitar que la gente
protestará
el reconocimiento facial es un software
que analiza la imagen de una cara y crea
una red de coordenadas que mapean los
detalles faciales como la distancia
entre los ojos y esas cosas
esas coordenadas son únicas en las
personas es tu mapa facial y está
clasificado como información biométrica
única que podría ser emparejada con
otros datos queden más información
ahora este sistema de reconocimiento
facial en Moscú funciona con algoritmos
producidos por una empresa bielorrusa y
tres empresas rusas pero haciendo caso
al famoso dicho nadie sabe para Quién
trabaja según la investigación de
routers al menos tres de esas compañías
han usado chips de las firmas
estadounidenses enviria corp e Intel
Core junto con sus algoritmos Y esto no
significa ni que envidia ni que Intel
hayan violado sanciones pues dejaron de
enviar sus productos a Rusia en 2022
además de acuerdo con routers una de las
empresas rusas y la bielorrusa
participaron en un programa de prueba de
reconocimiento facial desarrollado por
Estados Unidos destinado a evaluar
tecnologías emergentes y dirigido por la
rama del departamento de comercio una de
las firmas recibió 40 mil dólares en
Premios en dinero otorgados por una rama
de la inteligencia estadounidense son
numerosas las personas que tras
protestar Y ser identificadas por las
autoridades rusas han tenido que huir de
su país
lo único que ha cambiado desde mi punto
de vista es que el estado ha ganado un
nuevo instrumento de represión que puede
ser usado para detener a disidentes y
para realizar acciones intimidantes
contra opositores detenciones
preventivas sin razón
en Rusia estamos acostumbrados a vivir
así como un gran hermano es algo de la
unión so y ahora en Rusia Tenemos un
gran hermano que te vigila todo el
tiempo entonces la gente no puede hablar
sobre asuntos políticos o cosas así
Bueno vamos a cambiar de tema y vamos
ahora a Australia donde un equipo de
ingenieros biomédicos de la Universidad
de nueva gales del sur desarrollaron un
robot flexible que se puede utilizar
para imprimir biomateriales en 3D
directamente dentro del cuerpo humano
algo que hasta el momento no era posible
ha sido denominado f3db y cuenta con un
cabezal de impresión de tres ejes que
puede doblarse Y torcerse utilizando
sistemas hidráulicos en la punta de un
brazo robótico suave la boquilla de
impresión puede imprimir formas pre
programadas o puede operarse manualmente
si se requiere una impresión más
compleja
desarrollamos un nuevo tipo de impresora
3D flexible que puede realizar
impresiones de múltiples capas de
biomateriales dentro del cuerpo y esta
tecnología también puede usarse como una
especie de herramienta endoscópica que
puede ayudar a remover tumores
cancerosos dentro del cuerpo por ejemplo
en el cáncer de colon o el cáncer
gástrico recordemos que la bioimpresión
3D es un proceso en el que Se imprime el
tejidos con una especie de biotinta y
células vivas para reparar problemas
internos como daños en órganos o la
ruptura de vasos sanguíneos son
justamente esas células vivas las que
permiten que las estructuras
artificiales se fusionen naturalmente
hasta ahora no se puede imprimir dentro
del cuerpo las partes se creaban afuera
y con una cirugía se insertaba dentro
del cuerpo un procedimiento que para los
responsables de este proyecto es
altamente invasivo
s son buenos para trabajar con el cuerpo
humano porque en su mayor parte son
hechos con materiales como elastómeros
de silicona y por ello pueden ofrecer
interacciones seguras con el cuerpo lo
segundo es que los robots suaves ofrecen
alta flexibilidad y adaptabilidad por lo
que pueden caber en cualquier área del
cuerpo humano
el prototipo más pequeño desarrollado
hasta el momento tiene entre 11 y 13
milímetros Algo similar a una endoscopio
comercial no obstante los responsables
dicen que podría ser más pequeño en el
futuro
y finalizamos con un particular
dispositivo creado en China que permite
que estando a distancia dos personas
puedan besarse Sí así como suenas un
dispositivo llamado mua que tiene que
emparejarse con una aplicación móvil
para funcionar a simple vista son labios
de silicona pero que recubren numerosos
sensores de presión y movimiento que
recrean la sensación de besar
tengo una novia que también está en
Beijing pero viaja mucho así que
constantemente no nos vemos creo que
puede ser una herramienta emocionante
para cuando no nos vemos por ejemplo
cuando las cosas no están bien entre
nosotros podemos usarlo como herramienta
para mejorar nuestras relaciones
el dispositivo también Reproduce los
sonidos del beso que son grabados
previamente por los usuarios y en el
caso de parejas es posible programar la
aplicación de manera que sólo puedan
enviar y recibir estas demostraciones de
la misma persona para quienes están
solteros incluso hay una hay un banco de
besos guardados así llegamos al final de
este espacio ustedes Les agradecemos su
sintonía continúen con nosotros que hay
más en France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]